I have the games open right now I'm
looking at all the oh hey whoa whoa how
do you undo that why can't I change the
picture all right after we just play I
guess [ __ ] I don't know are you only
trying to get the background I'm sorry
it's downtown that's oh helpful all
right there is no right player here I'm
red okay I'm ready so you're the color
of yeah
I'm ray so wait it's green but I'm green
no no wait it's orange but he's blue and
marks white but he's red and I'm
powerful but I'm green it makes sense
sure how do we do this so you pick mark
you go first so you pick up a card off
the deck just draw one if you you have
to click and drag if you click and hold
on it you pick up the whole thing click
and drag real quick and then right click
I think to flip it over maybe Wow X X to
flip it over while you're holding it X
there's a button for that oh no that's
not it
I think if you right-click and move your
mouse maybe you got to 1212
Wow all right watch me 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12
boom now is it clockwise its clockwise
right does that mean I'm next
yeah yeah yeah very impressive ready for
this boy's sick draw bro used to rotate
damn just move your damn thing would you
1 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
any one of your something nerd they move
one man forward 11 squares any one of
your margin men may change places Lenny
one Marshall man of any opponent oh [ __ ]
you should have changed well I didn't
have any margin man you can't you can't
pull the start they have to be on the
outer out of thing for that to be a
thing yeah all right must either move
one man for ten squares or move one man
backwards one square okay if you land on
someone else's character I think they
get pushed back to start like this and
like if you land if you land on one of
these you know oh and if you hit someone
while you're doing that you knock them
back to start I'm pretty sure okay so I
could have moved a man out but I don't
think I can if I have a guy blocking no
I don't think you're gonna have two guys
in the same spot I'll draw again let's
say draw again or move one man for two
and draw again is the draw again only if
I take wait you not get to take a man
out of start oh [ __ ] did I do it wrong
oh maybe we did the whole table and I
were like just you know doing it our way
you might be food I'm gonna let mark
keep his huge lead
I gotta back make sure I need to make
sure that the one was well whatever does
someone said of one or two I've drawn
you got a one I think you're good so
then I moved to now I draw again yes
yeah
one man forward eight spaces a1 a2 you
three four five sheep Shepherd hey oh so
good right there
ten must either move one man for ten or
move one man back well [ __ ] me I guess
fine okay so we we can't we can't get
people out of the gate until you get a
card that's like good yes Billy
so your big lead man here is a cheater
pretty much no a masu of one man for 12
squares must know hello every other
syllable mark that doesn't seem fair
thanks numbers i [ __ ] mark a man may
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't even draw
card to get a guy out like I feel like
maybe you're just winning you're just
winning you're right I am you're right I
am
you're just legitimately sorry take one
man from your start place I place on any
margin square occupied by an opponent
and return that opponents man do it
start
oh oh wait here go that's bad for Wade
so I cheat and then he gets to [ __ ] me
yeah no I'm oh he's just he's just
meeting you at a board game Wade calm
down [ __ ] watch your language I
didn't change my stream to say
game watch your language ah [ __ ] I
turned a knob on my audio interface
everything's changed all right here we
go watch your [ __ ] language
I can do it too got you be good okay
wait would you make your goddamn play
you bastard three one you guys are
making such exciting moves there
backwards for squares [ __ ] wait I just
remembered doesn't the game start like
your first move is moving a guy out
because otherwise have been waiting
there forever I think I remember you're
supposed to move a guy out I don't know
is there [ __ ] instruction manual I'm
all we do it the internet classic rules
each player chooses four pawns of one
color and place them in their start one
players let's play first each player
draws one card and follows instructions
to begin the game all the players four
pawns are restricted to start player can
only move them out on the rest of or if
they draw a 1 or a 2 2 places the pawn
directly outside start - does not
entitle you to move fair enough fair
enough all right I'm wrong
go ahead oh there is a rule 3 a
relaxation start when a young player is
playing especially when learning the
game our relaxation is offered allowing
their one of their pawns to begin the
game already on the board you got baby
rules in your star player oh man I
wonder who I'm gonna take skirt aw [ __ ]
I thought you were still gonna [ __ ] me
I want another shot this hang on I'm
ready put that there I got it
got them take that [ __ ] yeah thank you
I feel taken guys already about to go
home yeah I'm two spaces from home
[ __ ] you guys start the game
over
suddenly you're having frame drop issues
glad there red boy wanna mention because
I'm getting some [ __ ] in my own comments
didn't have the baby rules because I was
a baby probably I was very young when I
first did this so three and three years
ago market hole Christmas with mama
flyer buddy you start with a player on
the you could start with one of them out
on the board okay don't be mad have to
like give him the advantage the moves
incredible you 0:03 coming for you
oh just you wait mark I'm right here
he's right there I'm waiting three four
five six seven eight eight please close
enough one two three four five
haha nicely played you earned that one
but yes I did her than that one he
didn't really earn that one I got one
ferret suffering for so long okay
whatever
remove one man forward seven or split
the move between off only you had two
men on the board you know what I get
with a seven one two and then slide and
then oh my God look at this one two
three four five oh sorry you guys are
about to get destroyed
that was a serious ITIL was nine comes
out with which I will sorry you oh boo
okay we're not whatever
Hey for that's the Pratt's a pretty good
move force pretty good bud
thanks man wait have you got a single
high number card it's not about how fast
it's about how fast wait Harden's go
you're supposed to move backwards for
cuz I just heard one two let's move I
can't okay
one two three four one two
I can't the safe zone right so I just
moved warning - and that's it I think
your safety is your you're stuck in the
song for backwards whatever I'm here not
going to know what happens if you were
to land like right here you see oh
that's um you get the big dick if you
have a dick okay let's move one man for
ten or move on man backwards one heaven
it now wait what are the odds you're
gonna get it - you know who you have to
hit you don't have to hit anybody you
don't have you really don't have to wait
if you right-click you can attack him
I cannot be separate look I feel like I
was winning at the beginning of this
well I got better than two I got a [ __ ]
you card
well alright okay apparently you can't
slide on your own color so you don't
slide past on your own color slide
[ __ ] so mark I treated a little bit
data too but that's fine story of my
life man what can I do how oh no if a
part is forced to move backwards they
move out of the safe zone oh [ __ ]
no no I'm gonna do it I'm gonna play by
the rules I'm out like you mark I happy
no wait don't slide on your own color
slides oh not on your own but all the
other ones you do yes yes on any on any
slide that's not your color you slide on
it thank God we have chat here to keep
us up your green guy out left mark alone
and kept you from thank God that didn't
happen yeah well too late now it's all
gone in the past mark play quick do it I
do it here we go I've now weighed no
come on man no over here too but let's
just stop the dickery
okay I think that's good right yeah Wade
I think Wade sees the play okay you're
high now I want you to count them out
it's fine it's Coe don't do it Wayne
don't do anything just run away it's
fine one little inebriated but that's
okay wait listen
hey buddy the word gets more
oh yes oh that's the good stuff yes get
away from me se10 move here no move your
front guy come on baby come on man hey
come on man 12 spaces I'm just getting
this guy safe I'm just going for a full
full hog here I think this card is draw
again anyway I think that's draw again
ha that's the whole deck there we go got
one Wow holy [ __ ] Oh what if I can't do
that well you technically can't you have
to skip the exit ah maybe you just don't
go I don't know I don't think you can
skip the exits though that was Bob dude
bob has to go around again
no you have to skip the exit No yeah
what if you can't do that maybe but just
means you skip the X 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
[ __ ] whoops job now for bud oh wait you
just lose your turn I'm trying to read
the rules Prairie chat I feel like you
shouldn't have to pass start that way
but oh it says you skip your turn if you
cannot move exactly to home so I just
lose my job okay gotcha okay just one
jump on by their battery or 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12
ooh you're in that little special spot
look at that seven most oh listen way
hang on wait job you can have all the
yellow pawns whatever you want
I can't beat a blow job but I as as who
do I want to dick baby don't you already
past me you can't go back now you can't
go always you of course wait breeze damn
it that's all good it's okay marks Nexus
Bob no worries my next no no next no you
just went so no to those I mean like I'm
going to take him out
never mind he's [ __ ] gone one man
forward it swears
well I can't do anything so either move
one man forward ten so guess I might do
that one two three four five eight nine
ten well I like cut out one two three
four five six seven eight nine okay yeah
you just cut out it sounded really
awkward all right wait do your thing
may change places with any margin man of
any other what's that beam anyone on the
outer anyone moving around the margin is
the outside my guys safe
you put him back in his start I'll do I
really it just has two places I just
I've just being an [ __ ] marketed that
move to you is not so bad by yeah I
think we know who it is
would you get your Bluetooth bag off me
that one makes it go back to the start I
did have a sorry where's my sorry go
there this important to you I just want
gonna just okay there got it fixed go
ahead mark alright between two men well
I would have had two men go get Bob he's
blocking his own exit true yeah well
well I don't I don't know no I wouldn't
think so but I don't let's chat another
room yes yeah of course you can walk
over your own guy hmm
there you go he's right there I'll drug
in that's like the whole deck hang on
there you go isn't there a way to just
like draw one or some on land forward
three squares
oh that's doing because I can really
play some risky maneuvers there or get
off my own started definitely move that
bottom left guy way bottom left
according to who he means who the guy
the guy near mark they should
start space I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have done anything exit there you know
it's not you're not cock-blocking nobody
no it's good
this is patently unfair because you've
got every character out and you're all
congregated in your home zone yeah I
feel like something so little dickie
here mark just go on then
I feel like something like could if I
could cheat he doesn't hurt me at all
wait he moves me back five spaces nice
one
yes that's fair that was the strip you
always claimed that was the story coming
in it's not your fault Mark's a
brilliant strategic mind good job
whatever exactly yes I'll get another
guy out here so I could block my own
exit 1 2 3 4 ha ha ha 5 6 7 there I like
it sounds good to me I don't like is
this the last one I think that's the
last one yeah 3 almost as many as you
need I don't slide on my own right we're
definitely certain yeah we don't flip it
on your own color glad that's not a rule
all right now wait oh yeah - I think I'm
just gonna get off this thing I didn't
try like that you're grouped up for easy
targeting over there yeah one man
forward three squares perfect that's a
good one that's a good one
[Music]
I can go from my own start space to
three blocks away hosted this game wait
I just moved you forward okay gave you I
appreciate you not sitting me to start
but also [ __ ] you yeah mark you're so
close bud you can do it you can all wait
do you have backwards no no I think you
can forfeit well it says you must either
do 24 backwards so I guess you have to
do one backward making progress boys
dancing around there's like a rabbit
here alright you can be the last bro out
yeah but I don't want to be on your
[ __ ] spawn so we're just gonna all
right good play good play good play good
play guys really chugging along [ __ ]
it's okay because the actual move is
just to do that that's true I would have
jumped all over you [ __ ]
all right oh no that's not what you want
oh you can't do either of those it
doesn't say must say you have to yeah so
maybe you don't have to you could change
places forfeit move if you do not wish
to change places and is impossible to
move 11 squares so you don't have to you
don't have to do nothing alright well
making progress boys good move mark
can move some of your far back friends
yeah I'll move forward right there
I got three left so we're gonna do that
yeah my would you have to do this one
yes yeah you can't okay whatever all
right it's fine it's good
well oh [ __ ] yeah I guess I can't do
that one that's not 12 isn't one anymore
zone 8 no go ahead there's where I
suspect that there's a rule here because
it's like you must move one man forward
that's a unless you can't though unless
you can't but you can if you skate right
past your safety zone right into the
middle of it because I distinctly
remember there's a there's a chance when
I was a baby okay that plate was babies
like it's it's not in the rules man what
if you what is much I find where that
doesn't really help you do this just so
I don't risk waiting that is actually
probably a good call yeah you would have
you would have enjoyed it you would like
what of it
wouldn't you so what of this you
wouldn't I would have you would have oh
that was backwards two squares I still
cook so funny seven eight nine ten one
away from a fun little slide all right
my turn huh okay hey last boy all right
move backwards Lord what is that I feel
like the nest market to be an
empty-nester I I don't I I like you
don't want to be any semester
ya know no one does you've got pieces
out but they're all like within 5's
places it's okay buddy we're all in the
same boat together it's fine that mark
could work I don't have any start boys
oh man is on your start or no opponents
men move is forfeited oh wait let's
count that out one two three four five
six seven eight nine
[Applause]
[Music]
for first place guys while I don't know
if that's a I think you should move this
guy from your start forward three four
like this helps me I guess this guy one
two nice play backwards one two I moved
him forward two and then I moved him
backwards for god dammit
mark are you actually quiet or you are
tied for first place right now tied for
first baby what a turnaround one man
backwards force I'm not eight huh
I don't know if I can do that one is a
four five six
yeah I guess I guess I don't move yeah
yeah
you could move out of your home if you
wanted to that's true you could leave
first eight one two three four five six
Oh oh [ __ ] one two three four don't
celebrate the we're all tied for first
oh wait turns on the other foot now just
happened there one man forward three
squares wait if you slide into your own
guide you say you can't you can't do
that I think to go my man
thank you that mom a lot oh [ __ ] well I
drew works I will find you do know you
know where I live all right well I'll
take that
[Music]
really happy for all you guys do not
slide that guy wait please get a one two
three four five six seven in the
distance not through the knots or
discord but in real life you just hear
Marg like across the country oh my god
chick-fil-a no it's not this time not
this time what is it
it's Wendy stuff yeah yeah your pieces
okay this is good three four five six
[Applause]
for a second every same time for a
second that means something
[Music]
and look at that mmm you really just
full-on mouth eating right now on your
stream with your mouth on stream oh oh
all right wait see how do you give me
that half a board worth of progression
do it for me with I want you to do it
Bob Bob do it obviously the choice under
your seat wave effects - mark - five
five five six one two - if you want wait
it's a dick oh that's your judgment at
all that one of us is closer to murder
than the other so do it
maybe that will influence your decision
probably oh it's a split decision here
in check Bob you can slide I don't think
that's how that works
what it is well then I get to slide 2 so
yeah I'm pretty sure that something I do
like sliding don't like Friday oh well
yeah you realize that helps me mark yeah
I know but it also I hope I get an 11
but double slide no no two three four
hey what's up wait how's it going over
there oh [ __ ] son is that wait wait wait
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11
it would have been cool it would have
been cool chutes and ladders this is
sorry
Wow Wow all right mark how many places
away are you one hang on set the thing
like that like that sorry please my
piece just died uh-huh you get your guy
back
yeah you just [ __ ] off no it's just uh
uh oh okay another one
good god yeah so uh it one no 1 2 3 4 5
so I'll just miss the slide Hey for
first time for first time for first last
card I wonder what it is
please Oh better run mark you know ba
he's gonna get up move backwards like a
forward progression is not what Bob does
you're not wrong I'm coming for you mark
this time I'm going forwards
yeah no way you don't know how all right
here Oh
jinkies a lottery ad damn it 1 2 3 1 2 3
4 5 Oh
I beg of you wait stole my five come on
now come on now come on now that's good
you go backwards a spin wait two three
four oh good point yeah no I didn't I
was just there I just I just had to
point that out mark I appreciate that
ah you're welcome I don't know why I
thought that was 9
oh that's not what you want to see hey
how's it going bud Pub G commentary oh
you don't want to see it you hate to see
it there's something guy gets injured in
the NFL oh you hate to see it alright
well Nick meanwhile I will proceed to
not get [ __ ] I've lost count your
mouse move you were like what 3 1 1 to
move backwards 1 ok it's ok it's ok
give me the fork give me the four give
me the four ok well give me something
else doing it now ha I'm out from the
idea that I'm a guest sorry card I'm
gonna really give you the business Bobby
see we'll see
full form oh no 400 you're safe I'm safe
I'm safe 7 could dick you know he has to
give all the so that's the wrong way man
it's alright alright what's where were
you where was your piece
what's your accounting assistant one two
three four wait so you were here I don't
know that's correct the one he was doing
before was not correct it was just like
one
flower I counted for as long as I count
my head that's how many moves it's right
no no no no sorry sorry three month at
sit sorry I thought you still had
someone you could move I was trying to
be encouraging no you Bob I don't
because you count weird ooh or move any
of my margin no you just moved into the
safe sure let me just go ahead and 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
it's just not fair before mark draws are
sorry I hope I get a 5 or a 3 or a 3
sorry all right
ok here we go I know I know how 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12
nevermind 1 2 3 4 5
Yahoo everything's gonna bark good
everything's coming up mark house two
three oh wait it's like Oh from behind
victory on this one how much of an
advantage I had at the beginning of this
game it really should we let you cheat
so much I'm I'm gonna get a sorry piece
I know I'm gonna get a sorry card and
you're gonna be you're gonna regret it
oh well you must move one player back
one I believe you're gonna regret it
all of you you're gonna be sorry imma be
like I'm gonna be like the ugly kid in
high school and then I got through
college and I got so hot Drock in 12 I
feel like 1 2 6 7 8 9 10 11
almost home lady you're like it's just a
little unfair but
[Applause]
I don't want to explain to you why
that's dumb but that's dumb
I know alright here comes my reverse
sorry
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh wait totally 3 to death right now
he's not gonna he won't do it 3 it's a
3/3 him to death he's too nice she
wouldn't do that to me he wouldn't do
that
that's right close enough I guess I
can't quite go there with 11 so I guess
I just switch places with him you switch
places with Marc
do I have to this way there's one where
you can form right you can you can
choose not to if you can't move you
don't have to switch I will choose not
to I don't wanna put him behind me that
feels dumb it's you're talking like he's
angry about something you could you keep
[ __ ] him but how many times have you
gotten the dragon card I've well that's
not what you want to see okay
let's start in two three four five six
I'm like the really sad kid at his own
birthday party you just cannot get going
in the right direction
oh that's alright eventually we're gonna
go the other direction
Hey
oh well that's not what I needed we
really need to do something about God's
last piece okay but how's it going here
on man I hope I don't get a move
backwards for that would suck that was
supposed to be mine yeah sure one two
three four five six seven eight ah okay
oh my god let Bob get a war no one a
while Bob to draw a card I've gotten
every seven in this entire deck six
seven hey Mark it looks real safe in
there Ted how many twos so I get two
well balls or backwards one okay bust
okay
I'm going to Bank 800 tied for first
first anybody could win except for me
I have no chance oh how safe you are
that's it's not gonna work out for me oh
no no wait wait could still have to move
backwards out of his safe that's not
what you want to do you were the safe
zone really got you know what buddy
you were you were trying to get the
sorry it was your goal and you really
nailed it
nailed it man thank you for recognizing
that not many people recognize my hard
work real happy for you dude I wasn't
talking to you wait no yeah no no no no
no ah [ __ ] you guys won and that's what
yes and I feel like I've been I believe
in you to ruin this for Wade I want you
to do it that does feel good no it's
closed it's closed wait that's your card
Wade sorry you can't right that's what I
had
no I'm fine I do try again if you get
four you lose no that's fair that's fair
that's fair that's fair
all right extra win I won that I can't
my sorry and here's my reverse sorry
[Music]